cellphone contracts they may be a thing
of the past we've been doing a lot of
complaining about things the internet
and Airlines now we're going to talk
cell phones this one might be a positive
story here the CEO of verizon Lowell
McAdam is saying he's going to consider
killing a cell phone contracts contracts
if quote consumers demand it you know
t-mobile is dropping contracts now
people can just pay for a month and get
out and the new york times did I they
broke down the numbers and I thought
this was incredible if you were to go
with tmobile with a comparable plan on
verizon but instead of rising with
tmobile over two years you could save
about nine hundred and sixty bucks so
finally this these small groups you know
we've got four companies let's say that
run everything they're starting to do
things different and it might work to
our advantage how do you feel about the
the cell phone and freedom why are we
locked into these contracts I didn't
know t-mobile was still in business so
when I read that article haha cell phone
don't you the one that like the size of
a person when people say empty mobile
I'm like do you like the reynolds wrap
around the eaters on the TV it's a
mystery yeah um you know I don't know
it's it's it's we're getting robbed it's
like you know and then it's like a
two-year contract on your phone breaks
down inevitably I'm like two months
right before the contract you come in
and like you know the phones in three
parts and they're like Moyer if you sign
a new contract and get seven new phones
and you're just like oh it's just
handcuffed you know it's it's absolutely
ridiculous but you're so dependent on it
it's just I literally was attic went to
accomplish a hundred racist exactly
exactly you are I need to text the
people like I hate but I literally it I
I was going to a comedy club and I
forgot my phone and it just it felt like
the end of the world I was just like
this is this is insane you're just so
yes usual anybody's I was like the map I
didn't know where I was it literally
felt like I was like oh my god this is
like this is I would rather not have my
wallet yeah like I like it just it makes
you crazy and you realize how dependent
you are on it and they have you
yeah now we know who's calling us you
remember it was only about 10 years ago
that you would pick up a phone in a
house and not know who was on the other
end yeah now if you would never do that
on your cell phone would you ever you
kick up a handle notice they don't you
you had a ball blocked but you would
never pick up on bread why would I ever
pickle this thing could blow up and I
roll the dice and I answer and that I'm
like oh nothing I did yeah has anything
ever good come out of a random number
that's calling you know nothing well I
don't know about you boys on manhunt but
I don't know how that works but ya know
nothing for me personally yeah come on
um I switched cell phones last week
carriers because I moved to a new part
of LA okay and I had one bar and I could
not get cell phone service at my new
home how many bars yet now it's like
four or five it's like a beautiful thing
do you want to tell us who you switch to
AT&T and you're getting better not open
said before ever no I'm getting I n it's
like oh my i was with sprint and they
charged me $350 to leave so i will trash
them yeah and it's like I'm really
content i'm getting service and all
these was a couple dead spots but
everybody you know I'm getting so much
better service than I had in like while
people were working in my new house I go
who's your cell phone carrier how many
bars do you have an AT&T one you know we
did the test and it's it's kind of
crappy I used to live in the hills and I
used to live near this hill and there
were cell phone towers at the top and
they wanted to put a new tower up and
one of these neighbors was going around
saying sign a petition so they don't put
a cell phone tower up and everybody's
like are you crazy what is wrong with
you i want one in my backyard yes
exactly it's really like pathetic so
that's like our like I'm i know i'm
totally attached and we were literally
like we'll be in an area like how many
bars do like it is this is our
conversation now yes it's what we talk
we've started the show by talking about
texting and we're ending it talking
about service but but really these
contracts I mean there's can you think
of anything else that were held hostage
the way we are with these cellphone
contracts what if I talk about
terrorists and your anybody here whoa
there you go
exactly so no but really is there
anything else that we're so do you pay
out two years of anything else that you
do in your day to day I'd like to say
I've reached a level with a mortgage but
I haven't been not quite there yet when
you work for a stand-up comedy's
nonprofit company I don't know what
t-mobile will change the business of
verizon Falls then it's only a matter of
time it's like the airline business and
then they'll all then they will start
charging you per text because they
realize they're not making any money on
cell phones anymore and then I won't
have to be racist Oh full circle so you
can't help bonobos com is the official
outfitter of the Ruben report I want to
put you in this slim fit shirt go to
bonobos com enter code trr 20 for twenty
percent off your next purchase